[Music]
so the first question that i have is
what will be the state of our bodies
after
resurrection so it's three questions but
i'm going to ask you one by one so okay
what is our body the state of our bodies
the resurrection now if you go to luke
chapter 24 from verse 36
the disciples are in the upper room they
are scared to death they're expecting to
be done to them what was done to christ
he had told them he would rise mark 8 30
mark 9 mark 10 he told him he would rise
they didn't believe it now while they're
in the room the bible says and as they
thus speak that's luke 24 36 jesus
himself stood in the midst of them and
saith unto them peace be unto you but
they were terrified and affrighted and
supposed that they had seen a spirit now
keep this word in mind they supposed
they had seen a spirit or a ghost he
said to them why are you troubled and
why do thoughts arise in your heart
behold my hands and my feet that it is i
myself handle me and see for the spirit
hath not flesh and bones as ye see me
have christ is saying i am not a spirit
now this is the risen christ i have
flesh i have bones
and when he assaults when he had thus
spoken he showed unto them his hands and
his feet and while they yet believe not
for joy and wonder he said of them have
ye hear any meat and they given to him a
piece of a broad fishing of a honeycomb
verse 43 and he took it and he eat
before them before the means in the
present now christ is saying i have
hands i have feet i have bones i have
flesh and i eat i am not a spirit in
other words he came from the grave
physical
keep this in mind now let's go to uh
philippians chapter three let's read
verses 20 and 21 of philippians 3 i'll
pray again father continue to tell me
what to tell your people in jesus name i
pray amen philippians 3 verse 24 our
conversation is in heaven the greek word
conversation means citizenship and by
the way that's literal if you are two
child of god your citizenship is first
in heaven not in sweden or jamaica the
united states is in heaven now for our
citizenship is in heaven from whence
also we look for the lord this house of
the savior the lord jesus who shall
change our vile bodies that it might be
fashioned according to his glorious body
what does that tell us the body with
which christ came from the grave is the
body you and i will have when we come
from the grave and jesus makes it clear
in matthew in luke 24 36-43 he is
physical he said i have flesh i have
bones i eat food a spirit does not do
that and so the answer to the question
is our bodies will be physical flesh and
bones we will eat that's why we have the
tree of life with 12 minutes froze a
ghost does not eat
we will have a body like christ
glorified no longer subjected to illness
or whatever else or losing your hair
whatever else will have a perfect body
and that's the one christ had that's
what we'll have
you